上课啊，同学们。
嗯，好久不见。
上节课的时候咱还我还说呢，我说更新太慢了，争取咱一两周更新一次，不能再月更了。
没想到一眨眼。
这是。
白驹过隙啊，一个多月又过隙了，是吧？
咋回事儿？
所以说啊。
人就不能立弗来着，你知道吧？立完必破必倒。
这就像什么？你知道吧？
就是像那种你拍战争片儿。
然后大家在壕沟里。
这个冲锋之前隐藏在壕沟里，然后其中一个战友拿出一张照片给大家看，看这是我媳妇儿漂亮吧。
回去之后，我就要跟他结婚了。
他只要一立这个flag系列就有数了，对吧？肯定要挂了，回不去。
所以呢咱以后也不立flag了。
啥时候更新呢？就随缘吧，看心情吧，好吧。
反正你们也不能拿我怎么样，是不是？
尽量啊。
这个今天这堂课呢我们讲点。
实用的知识，实战知识好吧，因为咱是实战课程嘛。
不过在上课之前。
熟悉咱们课程的同学都知道，按照惯例。
咱们是要扯会蛋。
不是说故意要扯淡，对吧？没有必要填充这个时间又不干嘛。
不是故意要扯淡，关键是有时候很多问题啊确实也是。
需要讲一讲有一些课程以外的知识，我也希望跟大家分享和探讨。
今天咱们扯点什么蛋呢？
今天说几个。
算是哲学问题吧。
这几个问题呢很多同学问过。
也有。
这个这个这个。
不少人跟我探讨过，就不光是同学问很多生活中的朋友啊也也会跟我探讨这个问题。
类似于比较哲学的几个问题吧，我觉得有必要探讨一下，好吧。
探讨几个什么问题呢？第一个。
就是关于。
天赋和努力的问题。
这个问题我觉得很有必要探讨一下。因为老有同学问，而且问这种问题的同学啊，他往往不是在群里问。
他不会在班级里堂而皇之的问的，他都是发私信问我。
说老师。
我跟您这个课学了半年了。
我觉得自己好像没有天赋啊。
我会不会白努力了？竹篮打水一场空啊，到最好。
就问我这个问题。
这其实就涉及到一个。
关于天赋和努力。
到底哪个重要或者哪个起决定性作用的问题？
问这种问题的同学呢，担心自己没有天赋能不能成的这些同学啊。
他们抛出了一个重要的论据。
这个论据我也听过，呃，确实属实就是。
郭德纲老师说过。
郭德纲老师不是也收很多徒弟吗？教很多呃这个学员学相声。然后郭德纲老师说。
说一个演员能不能成角？
早就注定了。
天赋就在那儿吧。
能成的。
一下就成了，成不了的。
白搭。
所以郭德纲老师的观点是天赋更重要。然后呢，他也说那些没有天赋的，你就别折腾了，趁早改行。
是吧郭德纲老师的对这些同学的建议趁早改行。
然后咱们的同学呢也有这个担心，就问我这个问题。
我先说一下我的观点。
我认为。
努力比天赋。
为啥呢？
首先说郭德纲老师那句话。
他说的没错。
但是他说的话是有前提的。
他说你如果想要成角儿成腕儿的话。
天赋是比努力重要的。
你没有天赋，白努力也成不了角，成不了腕儿。
前提是成角而成腕啊，同学们。
这就是我们需要思考的第一个问题。
你学一样东西，你的目的是什么？
你做事情难道只是为了成局而成腕吗？
什么叫卷？什么是word，就是年入几千万。
行业里面顶级的那几个人物呗。
你做一个行业，如果成不了那几个人，你就不努力了吗？
明白这个意思吧？假设你现在去。
当公务员，然后你盘算了一下自己的上升路径，觉得这辈子可能也进不了。
常委。
对吧进不了国务院最顶尖的那几个人了。
你就辞职吗？
你就不干了。
你就放弃啦。
如果你去一家房产公司，房产中介上班卖房子，然后你看了一下，哇，我这辈子好像也当不成许佳印王健林那种千亿富豪了，我不干了，我不努力了。
你眼睛里面就盯着那几个顶流吗？
所以说第一个问题就是你的目标定错了。
做一件事情啊。
你考虑的应该是成为一个优秀的人。
成为一个有作品、有担当的人。
而不是一定要成为呼风唤雨的那几个角儿。
这个概率很小的。
而且。
没有天赋是一定不行的，而且不只需要天赋，也需要努力，还需要运气，还需要你的各种机缘巧合，贵人相助，对吧？我们说成功者有几个条件嘛？呃高人指点贵人相助，小人作祟嘛，是吧？
你得碰到高人，碰到贵人，碰到小人。
就是这个这个成角成外真的是个小概率事件，咱们不要去追求这个。
计花岁月的东西，好吧。
还有同学跟我呃就是。
举例子说，那老师打篮球总需要天赋吧。
对不对？我如果没有个1.9，没有个1.95米，我打篮球是不是就没有没有前途了，我就不打了，我就放弃了，打篮球总归需要天赋嘛。
其实也不是呀，你考虑打篮球需要天赋，你眼睛盯的是国家队呀。
你还是盯着那十几个成卷成玩呼风唤雨，一年几千万的人物呀。
你为什么不能努力打篮球？
成为一名优秀的。
裁判员。
低一级别比赛的运动员。
体育老师。
在场记者。
体育媒体的编辑。
不都可以吗？不都是在实现你的理想。
在在在这个行业中贡献力量呢？
所以说。
学编剧也是这样。
努力比天赋重要，你只要努力，就能成为一名合格的编剧，优秀的编剧。
对行业有贡献的编剧，不要眼睛只盯着最顶流的那几个腕儿。
明白吧？
而且还有个问题。
你不努力，你怎么知道你没有天赋呢？是不是天赋这个东西很难验证的。
不是说哎呀，他你看他眼睛滴溜乱转，好像很机灵，就一定比别人有天赋。
是吧有些人呆头呆脑的这说不定也很有天赋，没法判断，我也不会判断。好吧，所以这个问题以后。
这个这个大家不用问我了，我统一解答，努力比天赋重要。
你只要有正常的。
大脑。
你就努力就行了。
不用管别的事儿啊。
然后第二个问题。
就是。
关于我们这个影视作品的。
产品性和艺术性的问题。这个问题也是一个经常被讨论的。
有点哲学性质的问题，就影视作品这个东西到底是个产品还是个艺术品？
这个我们不过多讨论了，因为我认为。
我认为啊影视作品是一个具有艺术属性的产品。
也就是说，两者兼而有之，但我更愿意把它定性为产品，但是它有艺术属性。当然，有很多人认为影视作品是有产品属性的艺术品啊，掉个个啊也行，好吧，随便你。
总之，既有产品性，也有艺术性。
不要走极端，确实都有对吧？它首先它是个商品嘛，你得买呀，你得消费呀，对吧？还得在大众当中推广传播呀。
然后同时呢，他确实也具有艺术属性呀，他有艺术价值呀，对不对？这个咱都得承认。所以这个问题呢就两者皆而有之，没必要讨论。
他为什么会提这个问题呢？
因为马上接下来第三个问题，很多人讨论，特别是咱们这堂课的同学。
需要了解这个问题，就很多人问为什么？
为什么？
艺术作品。
明明是艺术作品，然后你们讲课的时候，老师给我们规定什么多少个要素，多少个序列，多少个节拍啊，分节目就是说。
为什么他有一个。
就一个标准化的一个。
操作呢既然是艺术品。
为什么会有一个？
生产标准。
也就是说，所谓的这些规矩。
规矩，然后这些条条框框。
为什么会有这些东西？
很多人不服啊。
很多人不服啊，觉得艺术创作是自由的啊？为什么要你们这么多规矩，这么多条条框框，把我束缚了，对吧？我想要创作，你把我束缚了。
这个问题呢我们就来回到第二个问题。
如果影视作品。
是一个产品。
那么他有规矩有条条框框，大家没有争议吧。
一个产品必须有标准化，必须有品控呀，有质量控制，对吧？有生产流程呀。
有生产规范呀。
对吧有合格的标准呀。
这就是如果是作为一个产品讲规矩，一点毛病都没有吧。
那我们说如果是作为艺术品呢？
有些同学在这里放。
发迷惑就是说他更看重艺术品那一块。他说艺术品为什么还那么多条条框框呢？
艺术品也有。
跳跳晃晃啊。
同学们呢。
你们不了解什么叫艺术品，就觉得艺术是自由的，也不知道是哪来的歪里。
艺术之美在美学导论里面。
分为三部分说艺术之美。
第一叫。
格律。
第二叫创造。
第三叫情感。
也就是什么意思呢？
一个艺术作品如果称之为美。
一般来说，符合这三个方面的美。第一，格律之美。
格律之美就是规矩之美。
他的符合规矩。
明白吗？
第二，创造之美除符合规矩之外，你得有自己的创造性，有自己的特点呢。
懂吗？不能千篇一律啊，有创造性。第三，情感之美。
一个艺术作品符合了格律和创造之后，得让人产生情感。
没有情感。
这个艺术品也不能称之为美。
明白吗？
就好像一个姑娘。
一个漂亮姑娘，漂亮姑娘漂亮到一定程度可以称之为艺术吧。
啊，艺术之美呀。
那这个姑娘的艺术之美是不是也分这三部分呢？
首先都有格律吧。
首先得有格律吧，你说一个姑娘特漂亮。
少一只眼。
缺一条腿。
当然咱们。
我强调一下。
不是说残疾人就一定不美。
但是。
有残缺确实很难符合大众审美的格律之美，明白这意思吧？
所以我们判断一个姑娘的艺术之美。我们说首先这个姑娘哎周正为什么说周正呢？就是格律啊。
对不对？这这个是对称吧的。
是吧腰得细，腿得长，屁股得跳吧，这些都是基本格律嘛。
对吧。
得有格律，然后呢还得有创造，有姑娘得有自己的特点呢。
你千篇一律整容脸，那也不行，必须有自己的特点。
对吧不能完全流水线。
有创造。第三就是情感，一个漂亮姑娘符合了格律之美和创造之美。你为什么觉得她那么美呢？
是因为你对他有情感。
让人产生情感也是一种美。
所以说你看艺术之美啊，依然把格律之美放在第一位。
明白吗？
所以同学们啊。
一定要牢牢记住这一点。
咱们这个课的意义也在这里，我跟你们讲这么多规矩，这么多方法。
你如果打心眼里觉得哎呀，艺术是自由的，我不要方法，不要规矩，那你就错了，那你就可能就不美了。
不美了。
明白吗？
所以说。
为什么会有那么多规矩和条条框框？
从产品的角度。
必须有从艺术的角度。
他依然有。
好吧，然后关于这个啊，有很多同学经常喜欢举返例。我在前面课上好像也跟大家说过，我说有很多同学举个反例就以为自己有理了。
比如说你跟他说吃烟有害健康，他就说他有个舅姥爷，又抽烟又喝酒，活到了99，对吧？
我们说这就叫举反例。举反例。
并不能证明任何东西，咱们的同学一定要学去学点逻辑。
懂一点逻辑，你才能写剧本。
懂一点逻辑，你才能构建剧本。
你得有基本的逻辑举法例的同学啊，我就是说他连基本的逻辑能力都没有，好吧，因为这叫幸存者效应，明白吧？
不懂幸存者效应的，自己去网上搜一下，我这里就不浪费时间讲了，好吧。
这是第三个问题。第四个问题哎，第四个问题也。
第四个问题也非常的有意思啊，也非常普遍。就是关于。
一个故事的真实性的问题。
一个故事，一个影视作品的真实性的问题。啊这个问题非常有意思。
我给大家讲一种情况啊。
比如说我们开会的时候啊，我们一帮编剧开会的时候。
我们就假设今天在设计人物。
然后。
我们就是会觉得哎这个人物好像这样不合理耶。
对吧这这这个人物设定的不好不合理。
不真实。
然后就突然就会有一个人说跳出来说。
这个人物就是我从生活中。
照搬过来的，我生活中就有一个一模一样的这样的人物。
照搬过来的怎么会不真实呢？
搬过来的怎么会有问题呢？就用就可以了。
或者是。
这个剧情中有一件事儿，然后大家觉得啊这个事儿好像不太。
不太对。
放在这儿不好不行。然后也会有人有比如说某编剧就跳出来说这个这个这个事儿就是我们老家我们村发生的。
一模一样的，怎么会有问题呢？它是没有问题的。
对吧。
就是关于一个真实性的问题，哎，这里就有一个很奇妙的地方啊就是。
你说一个故事，一个剧本要不要追求真实性？
其实是要的。
因为我们往评价一个故事或者评价一个一个一个一个作品。我们经常说哇，这里面的人物活灵活现，跟真的一样。哇，这里面这个事儿啊让我感同身受。
哇，身临其境，特别真实。
特别真实。所以我们经常用真实。
来评价一个故事之好。
对不对？
所以呢就造就了有些人认为，那就越真实越好呗。我胸口往里面确实有的人确实发生了个过的事儿，我放进去，那不就最真实了吗？还有什么坑？
可质疑和修改的吗？没有了。
对吧就是关于这个影视作品到底真实性好不好，要不要的问题。
这里。
趁今天这个机会一次给大家解决掉，大家以后也不需要再疑惑了。
真实性。
故事要不要追求真实性？
要。
但是追求的是。
艺术真实，而不是生活真实。
就是说真实分两种啊。
有艺术真实和生活真实，生活真实就是你生活中发生的事情1比1，你不管它合理还是不合理，奇葩还是不奇葩，它反正发生了，它就是真实的这就叫生活真实。但是不是所有的生活真实，适用于艺术作品，为什么呢？因为艺术作品有自己的艺术真实。
艺术作品如果一比1复刻生活，那叫纪录片。
对吧那叫照片。
对不对？如果1比1真实就是艺术的本质的话，就是审美的标杆的话，那画家都不用干了。
都会败给照相机呀。
明白这意思吧？
所以故事的真实性，我们探讨的所谓的真实性真。我写的这个故事很真，是艺术真实。
不同意生活真实。
举一个极端的例子，比如说那个那个那个那个那个变形金刚。
这个这个外星来的那些大机器人，擎天柱、威震天，那是真实的吗？
那不是真实的呀。
但是你去。
那个imax看那个变形金刚的时候，那个视觉效果，那个音响那个情节让你觉得很真呢。
对吧很揪心啊，很投入呀。
他是怎么做到的？他就是做到了艺术真识。
所以艺术真实呢。
艺术真实。
主要有哪几个方面的真实呢？艺术真实。
跟生活真实的区别啊，就是说你这个人和事儿可以是虚构的，但有些东西是不能虚构的。
就是艺术真实。
第一，最重要的。
逻辑真识。
就说你可以虚构人虚构事儿，但你不能虚构逻辑。
明白吗？
因果关系。
你不能去瞎搞。
符合逻辑真实。
2。
情感就是。
情感认识啊。
人和物可以虚构，但情感是实打实的呀。
你对擎天柱的情感。
对擎天柱的的爱，对对对那个那个威震天的恨是真实的。
对吧。
情感真实逻辑真实、情感真实。
然后第三，我们叫内涵真识。
一个故事内涵。
也是需要符合。
股市的真理的。
符合大家传统的认知和价值观。
所以说。
这是艺术真事，要做到这几方面。
当然了，对于我们影视作品来说，我们还有一样证实很重要，叫视觉证实。
叫视觉真实啊。你看为什么现在拍片，特别是。
这个这个这个。
科幻片。
特效片要花那么多钱。
花那么多钱搞特效吕棚啊、动作捕捉呀，哎各种电脑这个这个特效。
为花很多钱，为什么要这么搞？
他们说追求真实性。
但其实你有没有深刻思索这个问题啊？
它里边有个矛盾，就是说哎你们这个片子特效花那么多钱，为什么？他说我们要追求真实性。
我们问你一个问题啊。
你看你拍的是那种神仙大架，天神啊在天上飞放冲击波。
我们有人看到过神仙打架吗？
没有吧。
那你怎么知道你花一个亿做出来的特效，就比花五毛做出来的特效真呢？
说不定真实的神仙打架用的就是五毛特效呢，你有没有想过？
对吧。
所以你看他们为什么花那么多钱在追求所谓的真实，就是艺术真实。艺术真实是什么真实呢？在世界方面呢？就是大家对于。
这类。
虚构的。
事物的。
固有认知。
你得满足他。
你能满足它，然后呢，这就是所谓的视觉真实。
所谓的视觉真实。
所以我们平常探讨的一个故事真不真，讨论的是艺术真识，不是生活真识，好吧。
好。
这个。
今天上课之前啊就探讨这么几个问题，虽然是扯淡，但我觉得也有用，好吧，也有用。
帮大家解决一些问题。
正式开始今天的课程。
今天这节课讲点什么呢？今天这节课我想给大家讲一点。
实操的东西。
实际的东西。因为咱们这个课啊实战课嘛。
实战课咱得实战。
嗯。
我这个月呢。
确实也比较忙，所以才没有更新。
在忙什么呢？这个月啊公司有很多。
很多项目。
要送审，要报项目。所以呢在这个一个月之内看了大量的剧本，大量的梗概大纲，各种各样的项目。
没有100个也得有大几十吧。
看着眼睛都花了。
然后呢，我就发现。
即便是职业编局，因为我们公司交上来这些东西，那都是老老操作员们搞出来的项目，对吧？即便是职业编局，依然会犯一些。
共同的错误。
通通病。
还还还是会有这些问题。
然后呢，我觉得这些问题很有必要。
讲给我们的同学听一听。因为我们的同学啊，你只要看过前面的课程。
这个这个仔细看了，仔细跟着练习了。现在啊很多同学都能自己写剧本了，也有很多试着写过了。
我觉得这些问题有必要也讲给你们听，因为你们肯定也犯了。
好吧。
这就是几个。
算是间阶性的问题吧。
前面课程没看完的，没有理解透的，还没有自己写东西的这节课你可以不看。
你也听不明白。
你你没有这个体会，你没有写，你没有这个体会，好吧。
这咱是网课没关系，你可以反反复复往前看。然后呢，开始写东西的同学听一听今天这节课的内容。
我们谈几个，我们叫。
进阶问题。
进阶问题好吧。
进阶问题。第一个。
头大甚子小。
老生常谈的问题了吧。在业余业余组批作业的时候，有很多同学有这个问题，就是一动设定，后面没事，头大身子小的问题。
这个问题在。
职业编剧职业作品中依然存在。
依然存在。
我这个这个前面我在课上也好，答疑也好，我想好几次跟大家说过这个问题，提过。
不同的解决方案吧，我让你们少写前十，不要闪回，快速尽隙，激励前提说过很多这样的问题。
然后在这一个月当中呢。
我又发现了一个关键。
节点。
可能是导致这个问题头重脚轻这个问题的关键症结所在就是。
重点。
终点。
一个故事啊。
你开场了以后。
什么人遇到什么样的事儿，告诉观众，最后怎么解决，你也知道，总归是我们的主角，最后勇敢面对解决问题嘛。但是在这个过程中。
你洗了不精彩，没有洗。
往往是终点。
出错。
我们说啥叫重点？
一个电影一切为2，就中间那一刀，100分钟的电影就在50呐，1105分钟就是55那，中间那一刀。
那个位置那个位置是干啥来着？
在节拍器里面叫虚假的胜利、伪胜利或者虚假的失败，对吧？
我说在那个位置。
你如果没有找好那个点，没有把那个点做明确了。
确实容易头大身子想。
反过来说啊，你如果写完你的剧本之后，脑子里面有意识的先把你的终点理出来，这个问题是可以避免。
那我们就来说一下，在终点这个位置。
都能搞出什么样的事情，很多人不理解这个伪胜利啊，伪失败。
我们就用我们课上举过的例子给大家讲解一下什么叫伪生率微失败。
徐次郎的夏天。
啊，这个老片子好像今天还要上上上咱们的电影院是吧？这个呃菊次郎的夏天橘次郎夏天讲的不就是一个小男孩，没有妈妈，他妈妈不要他了啊，但他以为他妈妈在城里打工挣钱养活他。
对吧然后呢，他在这个呃一直也没见见不到自己的妈妈。然后他在这个夏天，他想进城去找他的妈妈。
这个小男孩，然后呢。
帮他进城的这个人呢叫菊次郎，也就是白野务。
就带着这个小男孩进城找妈妈。
终点位置是什么呢？
找到了。
他们历尽千辛万苦，路上没有钱，被人打，对吧？要饭，然后呢，终于到了城里，找到那个地址，找到他妈妈了。
小男孩的目标是什么？找妈妈找到了。
但是。
他妈妈并不是在城里打工。
不是在城里努力赚钱寄乡寄回乡下养活他，他妈妈早就嫁人了，早就又嫁人了，而且又生了一个小男孩。
愉快的生活，家里住着大house。
所以。
小男孩在终点这个位置找到了妈妈，但是是虚假的胜利。因为你找妈妈本来是想找什么啊？
找母爱嘛，你没有找到母爱。
这就是。
徐次郎的夏天的重点。
虚假的胜利。
虚晃一枪，重新调整目标再上征途。
你看是终点就是可以做这些事儿嘛，假胜利假失败。然后呢，调整目标，加大赌注，重新上路。
课上还讲过那个呀。
那个那个那个那个那个。
阿烦达。
阿凡达的终点，我在那一节课也给大家专门讲过。
他本来的目标是潜入。
那个那个那个外星人，纳美人里面。
这个这个打探他们的消息。
做卧底。
终点那个位置成功了，潜入进去了，人家认可你了，还给你这个受封仪式，说你就是我们的战士啦。而且对方那个纳美人酋长的女儿都让你给拿下了，对吧？因为封完战士以后，那个女儿带着你钻小树林，不就把事儿还都给办了吗？
终点，那不就是胜利了吗？你想潜入纳美人中。
做过底赢了。
成功了。
然后终点往后呢。
他不想做卧底了，他觉得纳美人挺好的，我们邪恶的地球人凭什么抢夺人家的家园？他本来是地球人这一伙儿派过去的卧底。
终点的位置卧底任务成功。
获得了情报，成功打入对方。但是接下来他选择我站在那美人有方，我不想让地球人侵犯这个美丽的家园。
这就是重点。我们说虚假的胜利。
调整方向再上征途，堵住加大全是在终点这个位置。
好啊。
这里大家先把这这一条记下来。
记下来你以后写完梗概也好，写完大纲也好，有意识的问一下自己，我的终点是什么？
我故事的中间点是什么？有没有打点？
有没有拐一下？
对吧有的话头大身子小的问题基本就解决了。
基本就解决。
第二个问题。
也是其实也是课上说过的问题。
主角的设定。
不具体。
主角不设定不具体的问题啊。
非常头疼。
很多同学很多这个这个编剧。
你设定一个主角，人设叽里呱啦写一堆。
最后他妈没实现。
因为你记得写实不，我这个主角很内向。
哎，我这个主角呢很腹黑，我这个主角很坚强。
我这个主角呢白莲花，哎傻白甜。
你这些描述啊，你最后在剧本里面没实现呀。
那么啥叫腹黑？
具体干啥事儿叫腹黑，对吧？
所以说。
我们可不可以换一种思路？
以后在咱们的人设当中啊。
少写性格。
少写形容词。
我们把它换成什么呢？
我给大家推荐一种思路啊。
我认为性格啊不如写。
价值与态度。
比如说价值。
态度。
比性格好使。
价值与态度我在。
哪一刻？
怎么写提案那一刻，我有教大家写人物小传，你自己回去扒拉扒拉。
我有没有告诉你们要写价值和态度？
绝对有。
我们说价值和态度是比性格好使的设定。我们往往忽略。
价值就是你的价值观呀。
你有你的价值观，你有的价值体系，所以价值这里往往会有。
带来一个观点。
对不对？
你有价值观，你就有自己的观点。
来有态度呢。
就导致。
行动的行差点又写错了。
有行动。
是吧。
你这样不就容易实现了吗？
我给大家举个例子。
影史上排名前几的电影肖申克。
的救赎。
肖申克的救赎里面就特别典型。
因为他是。
他有两个比较主要的角色，andy男主是安y，然后呢，男二是那个他的那个伙伴，这个故事的讲述者，那个黑人摩根弗利扮演叫reb。
是吧。
来，你如果说你给肖申克的救赎写人物设定。
你说他俩谁内向？
谁腹黑？
谁坚强？
谁呢？
白莲花谁是绿茶婊？
这是设定没有用。
你莫不如写他俩的价值和态度，也就是观点。
和行动。
特别典型的几个啊，就这两个角色的观点。
read的。
老黑人是本来就在监狱的，而且也是终贞监禁，对吧？服刑很长。
那个那个安迪来了以后，男主来了以后，男二给他说了一句话，说。
原话我忘了啊。
说。
希望是没有用的，在这个里面是没有希望。在这个肖申克这个监狱里面是没有希望。
但是我们的男医认为，希望还是要有的。
希望是美好。
所以你看。
这就是观点。
他们俩都是终终身监禁。
对吧男二认为没有希望。男一认为。
是有的，不管在哪，希望都是美好的。
都是美好，甚至那个那个男一要买一个小锤子的时候，买一个小锤子，男二以为他要越狱嘛，男二就跟他说这个监狱啊。
你挖600年。
大概能挖通。
对吧这就是他的观点，他认为没有希望。
但是我们的男衣呢哎舅娃。
就挖挖了20年。
挖筒。
对吧所以你看它的价值，它的观点是什么？
人要有希望。
他的态度是什么呢？坚持。
坚持不懈呀。
他就爱坚持故事中特别明显营造他的态度。
有一个支线情节是。
他在那个呃监狱图书馆呃工作，然后他想要改善这个图书馆的。
呃，环境他就开始给上级有关部门写信。
他一直写一直写写了多长时间？
五年故事名告诉我们，他写了5年的信，人家才回他信，给了他200块钱，告诉他，你别再写信了，我们也没有钱，没有这种预算，给监狱建图书馆，那给你200块钱，你对吧？你爱买点啥买点啥吧。
我们就想买你闭嘴，别再泄信了。
然后呢。
他继续写又写了3年，前前后后一共8年。
上级部门封了，寄来了很多书音响。
各种小玩具。
然后这个这个各种娱乐用品给他们建了一个。
阅览室。
把年办成一件事儿。
他的态度呀坚持呀。
所以你看。
这么好的片子，人家不需要去设定说这个人外向还有内向什么。
出鲁还是细腻，没有必要。
设定价值和态度。
才是人物设定当中。
比。
性格特点更重要的。
所以说。
咱们的同学啊以后写剧本的时候，这里也注意一下。
也注意一下，别犯这个错误了。
少写形容词。
给我找一找他的观点。
找一找他的态度。
好吧。
就是可以让你的主角更具体。
嗯。